foreign
CNBC did an article headline reads 50 of
workers are burned out and productivity
paranoia is making it worse
uh so let me tell you what pre uh
productivity paranoia is George I've
never heard of this term I know uh I
don't know it's paranoid no you're well
you're paranoid in general that's true
but productivity paranoia is the
position that companies via managers and
leaders are taking with the people that
work for them and the idea is is this is
specifically really related to remote
workers and hybrid workers remote
full-time remote or the hybrid workers
spending some time in the office and
then sometime remote and so we're seeing
it with uh keystroke tracking on your
keyboard I have heard about that
monitoring uh your key fob you know on
the days you're supposed to be in uh
softwares that uh we reported one story
of a lady who got fired because she
cooked something
in her kitchen and her computer was
spying on her she was working in her
kitchen at home
and she was in a phone related job where
she had to make certain amount of phone
calls and she had her computer open
and the computer
software they were able to have access
to it and they were watching her on the
camera cook something in her own kitchen
okay cook a meal for lunch I didn't know
it was legal to run the camera without
your knowledge this is just a real life
situation I reported on this story this
is a big trend on Tick Tock so the lady
got fired over it and they were spying
on her in her own home okay so this is
the productivity paranoia so hey we
don't see you we don't hear you are you
working the hours that we say You're
supposed to work okay uh and then you've
heard the terms the great resignation
right where we had nearly 60 million
people quit in the last 13 months the
number continues to truck along
September job report broke another
record of people leaving their jobs
um and then of course I know because
you're Mr Millennial and Mr Tick Tock
Mister all the things on social thank
you you know about the term quiet
quitting oh yeah which is a phrase that
was born on Tick Tock and it refers to
people who are doing just the bare
minimum so whatever is expected of me
I'm gonna do that I'm not going to do
anything more because I don't want to
burn out right and so you got all this
going on and uh the reality is is that
uh
ninety percent of workers this is a
Microsoft study so Microsoft has you
know office software and they did a
study 20 000 workers worldwide George
and this is the interesting dichotomy
all right between workers and leaders
okay ninety percent of workers report
they're productive at work
okay yet 85 percent of bosses say hybrid
work has made it hard to be confident
that those employees are being
productive right so the old idea the old
phrase out of sight out of mind plays
into can I be honest if I'm a worker
taking a survey why would I Market
myself as unproductive
right now obviously Microsoft did the
survey not the company they work for
right but still everyone thinks they're
more productive than they really are
yeah at the end of the day but this is a
true problem because when you're in
person I can see Ken at his desk I see
him in the meetings and with zoom you
might have a team meeting over Zoom once
a day but other than that yeah people
are going well I got my 48 minutes in I
finished my work for the day Ken why
does it matter what I do with the rest
of the seven yeah exactly and so what's
happening is you've got companies that
are saying I don't see you and and so
I'm going to track every movement
because managers are feeling the
pressure to report up to their
higher-ups that productivity is
happening
um which that's her that hurts culture
that hurts trust all the way around so
that adds to the burnout right because I
believe there are five causes of burnout
George at work and I'm curious you know
how many of our audience members are in
these are feeling these
um sources of burnout because burnout's
a thing but we've got to get to what's
the source of burnout one is a toxic
workplace what there's a lot of Gossip
backbiting politics lying going on
apathy things of that nature it's a very
toxic environment then there's your
overworked you just feel like you're
drowning the moment you pull into the
parking lot then there is you don't feel
recognized you're overlooked you're not
getting opportunities for promotions you
feel like you're not seen or you're
recognized for your work then there's
just straight up boredom you just have
no Challenge and then the final factor
that causes burnout is no purpose or
meaning in the work like you don't
there's no juice you don't love the work
the results of the work don't fire you
up so if you take all of that plus you
add in the fact that you feel like your
boss is your Nanny you've got big
brother happened monitoring you right
like you're in the crib go to sleep
George you know what I mean you know
that kind of thing and I think that's
all contributed to it and and one other
piece of data from this study this is
not just a worker issue this is a
manager issue compared with in-person
managers hybrid bosses struggle more to
trust their employees uh by a score of
49 to 36 percent and then they say they
have less visibility of their direct
reports work that's 54 versus 38 so
in-person boss is more trusting
hybrid or remote bosses not so trusting
and it's just creating a lot of tension
between the worker and the leader you
know it'd be a fun game to play if
you're listening and watching you put
the hand up and you go finger down if
you have a toxic culture finger down if
you feel like you're overworked finger
down if you feel overvalued and if
you're down to two fingers it's time to
peace out oh George that did you think
of that on the fly yeah that is how my
brain works that's impressive I was
actively listening but I was also going
that'd be a fun game and that's a good
game
so it works if you get down to one
finger one finger is a little different
that's uh it's a little bit different
attitude it's a spicy attitude different
reply if you're four out of five on that
list Ken you gotta go today yeah it was
absolutely right and we're here to help
with that you know leaders from an
entree leadership standpoint we can help
you uh in how you're communicating how
you're leading and then uh on the Ken
colemanship and I can help you I mean
again uh once you know what's causing
the burnout
it's like going to the doctor and going
I got sore knee the last thing you want
the doctor to say is well I've taken a
look at it and I can now tell you that
you have sore knee that's not what you
want that's Dr Coleman for you yeah you
want to know what's causing the soreness
get to the root of it let's get to the
in those five causes of burnout toxic
work environment you're overworked
you're underappreciated you're bored or
you have no meaning or purpose in the
work that can make you not want to come
into work very often and by the way not
only you don't want to come in it's
affecting productivity and that so
leaders are going I gotta track you I
gotta track you I gotta track you that's
not leadership that's Nanny ship and and
what followers are saying and people
that we're gonna go listen
I'll get the I'll get the work done but
treat me like I'm a human being treat me
with some dignity treat me with some
love show me how to do it train me to do
it better that's great leadership you
know so and Dave and I uh we just
released an entree leadership podcast
this week all about the difference
between a boss and a leader and
everything you're talking about that is
how would you sum it up that's bossary
yeah well I mean Dave talks about this
in the I'm not gonna I'm gonna tease it
here that's all I'm saying everyone
needs to listen to it but he talks about
all the things you're talking about does
the team feel valued do they care are
you pushing are you pulling how often
are you meeting with your team how
connected are you and that's one of the
reasons all you know 1100 of us are on
Under One Roof every day we just value
that as a team we think it builds
culture we think it builds trust we
think there's more productivity and it's
not from a big brother standpoint of if
Dave doesn't see you you're not working
but we just know the value of being
together in proximity physically and
Simon sinek I just interviewed him and
he said much of the same it's crazy how
much of it aligned yeah well you know
what's interesting about that I just
read some data nearly 60 percent of gen
Z
wants to work in person they do not want
remote work they are craving the
relationship Connection in the workplace
it's fascinating you don't see those
numbers of course with Gen X which is my
generation and Boomers but there is a
disconnect
between and again I'm not anti-remote
work okay if you can get it if you can
do it and be productive you got a good
healthy leader great but it does cause
all kinds of problems we're beginning to
see this in the data and Dr John
deloney's always talking about the
loneliness epidemic we're facing as we
just stare at our screens and lose
personal you know physical connection
with people and that's one of the
benefits I get from just being here
versus remote work you got to be way
more intentional about that in your
personal life I mean I just for a moment
want you to consider George how much
better your life is because you sit
three feet away from me I couldn't even
calculate it Ken I mean it's a measure
it's invaluable wow because we get to
say hi to each other and the high fives
the fist bumps that's a double blessing
it is in one room